en el vídeo pasado vimos cómo se puede
usar la inversa de una matriz para
resolver un sistema de ecuaciones era
una matriz chiquita de 2 x 2 pero pronto
vamos a empezar a hacerlo con matrices
de 3 x 3 y más adelante vamos a ver cómo
se haría para cualquier matriz de en
'por n no vamos a hacer ningún ejemplo
específico ni siquiera para las matrices
de 4x4 porque nos tardaríamos muchísimo
tiempo y por si te estabas preguntando
para qué hacer todo este relajo de las
matrices pues en este vídeo te voy a
enseñar otra aplicación de las matrices
que bueno es más probable que te la
enseñen en la clase de álgebra lineal
cuando la tomes en la universidad pero
lo que es realmente importante aquí y
creo que este es el ejemplo ideal es que
la representación con matrices es
simplemente una forma de representar
muchos tipos de problemas y algo muy
padre es que si distintos problemas se
pueden representar de la misma forma
esto lo que te dice es que en el fondo
son el mismo problema y si puedes
reducir un problema a otro que ya había
resuelto
todo el trabajo que hiciste para
resolver ese problema te sirve para
resolver el nuevo en fin veamos esta
otra forma en que se pueden usar las
matrices a ver entonces digamos que
tengo un vector a vector
y ese vector es igual a el vector 3
menos 6 de hecho ok recuerden que todas
estas son convenciones que lo inventamos
nosotros los humanos y que pudimos
haberlo hecho de cualquier otra forma
pero que se nos ocurrió hacer la de este
entonces pues vamos a poner nuestro
vector columna que es 3 menos 6 bueno 3
coma menos 6 o lo podemos dejar así
y también tenemos a nuestro vector b
que va a ser el vector 26
y finalmente tenemos a nuestro vector c
que es igual al vector 76
para que quede todo muy claro vamos a
dibujarlos en el eje cartesiana aquí
está el eje de las yes y aquí está el
eje de las x
y bueno nada más estoy dibujando esta
parte del plano cartesiano porque pues
es la única que vamos a necesitar
entonces pues ya vamos a graficar el
vector a que el vector a es el vector 3
como menos 6 entonces 1 2 3 y luego 1 2
3 4 5 y menos 6 o sea que nuestro vector
a se encuentra más o menos por aquí
ok y recuerden recuerden que los
vectores no están fijos no tienen que ir
a fuerzas de aquí que de hecho podemos
tomar este vector y moverlo del lugar y
moverlo arriba abajo cambiarlo de lugar
siempre y cuando tengan la misma
orientación y la misma magnitud o sea
siempre va a ser una línea de este
tamaño y con esta dirección
ahora vamos a pintar el vector b que es
2,6 o sea 12 y después 1 2 3 4 5 6 o sea
que el vector b está por acá
y finalmente el vector se son 7 en el
eje de las equis y 6 en el eje de la
siesta o sea 1 2 3 4 5
7 y 6 para arriba o sea hasta acá ya lo
teníamos entonces se encuentra más o
menos por acá obviamente me quedo chueco
el dibujo o sea no soy una experta
dibujando pero más o menos así está la
cosa
ok entonces cuál es el problema el
problema lo que queremos hacer es ver si
podemos escribir al vector c como una
combinación lineal de estos dos vectores
ok si podemos encontrar no sé llamémosle
xy unos números tales que multiplicamos
a por equis y le sumamos por b y eso nos
da el vector c de hecho ahorita ni
siquiera sabemos si realmente hay esos
dos números equis y que hacen que si
sumamos a equis veces más b ya veces nos
van a dar este vector pero pues por lo
menos tenemos que intentarlo
bien entonces lo que nosotros estamos
diciendo que estamos buscando es unos
reales xy tales que por equis
de por que sea exactamente igual c
buscamos estos dos numeritos que hagan
eso así es que pues vamos a sustituir
aquí los vectores a y b ok del a tenemos
el vector
3 - 6
por equis nuestro escalar x más el
vector b que es 26
por el escalar que estamos buscando que
es el número de y esperamos encontrar
estos xy que hagan que esto sea
exactamente igual a el vector 76
ok y pues por la forma en la que
nosotros los humanos definimos la
multiplicación entre matrices esto no me
lo van a creer pero esto es exactamente
igual a esta multiplicación entre
matrices
- 6
esta es nuestra primera matriz y se está
multiplicando por la matriz ya
adivinaron cuál matriz voy a poner aquí
bueno en la matriz x ye igual a 76 y
entonces si queda claro que esto es
exactamente lo mismo que esto a ver
hagamos la multiplicación ok
cuando multiplicamos la primera fila de
esta matriz por la primera columna de
esta matriz lo que nos queda es la
primera entrada o sea nos queda 3 por x
+ 2 por jay y eso tiene que ser
exactamente igual a 7 que es lo mismo
que nos queda aquí no ósea porque estos
dos son escalares entonces se meten
dentro del vector de esta forma
y entonces lo que nos queda es que 3x
más 12 tiene que ser igual a 7 que es
justo lo que teníamos por acá ok y lo
mismo pasa cuando hacemos la
multiplicación de la segunda fila por
esta columna nos queda menos 6x más 67
tiene que ser igual a 6 y de este lado
nos queda igual lo mismo menos 6x más 6
tiene que ser igual a 6 o sea que está
así es otra forma de escribir este mismo
problema
y tal vez ahorita tú estás diciendo a
jaén porque si este si es exactamente el
mismo problema que teníamos en el vídeo
pasado ok se acuerdan que teníamos por
ahí unas rectas que queríamos que se
interceptaran y bueno esas líneas esas
rectas eran las rectas 3x más 2 igual a
7 y menos 6 x + 6 e igual a 6 y bueno
para encontrar cuál es la intersección
entre estas dos líneas que es
equivalente a encontrar los números xy
jake que resuelven este sistema de
ecuaciones lo que hacíamos era escribir
a este problema con matrices y terminaba
haciendo exactamente igual a este
problema
ok entonces de hecho ya ahorita ya
nosotros ya sabemos exactamente cuál es
la respuesta cuál es el vector xy pero
pues vamos a repasar lo no o sea lo que
necesitamos hacer es encontrar
a esta matriz lo llamamos la matriz y lo
que tenemos que hacer es encontrar la
matriz a inversa y multiplicar la del
lado izquierdo de los dos lados del
igual
para que ésta se cancele con esta y
entonces ya nada más nos quede el vector
xy igual a la inversa multiplicando al
vector 7-6 ahora muy importante muy
importante siempre hay que recordar lo
que el orden en el que multiplicamos las
matrices es muy importante ok si
multiplicamos aquí la inversa del lado
izquierdo de estas matrices tenemos que
multiplicar la inversa del lado
izquierdo de este vector ok si yo
hubiera multiplicado por la inversa de
este lado eso habría estado
completamente mal bueno no completamente
mal hay algunos casos en los que si da
lo mismo
multiplicar del lado izquierdo o del
lado derecho pero en la mayoría de los
casos va a resultar algo completamente
distinto ok entonces multipliquen
siempre del mismo
bueno y para calcular a inversa lo que
tenemos es allí la inversa es igual a 1
entre el determinante de a y el
determinante de a es tres por 618 menos
2 x menos 6 o sea menos 12 o sea 18
menos menos 12 esos 18 más 12 que es
treinta y treinta por la matriz adjunta
de a y cuál es la matriz adjunta de a en
el caso de dos por dos pues tomamos
estos dos valores y los intercambiamos
al igual que en el vídeo pasado entonces
nos queda aquí un 6 y aquí un 3 y estos
dos los multiplicamos por menos 1
entonces nos queda menos 2 y menos por
menos 6 o sea 6
ok entonces esta es la inversa de la
matriz a y lo que tenemos aquí es que xy
es igual a la inversa por 7-6 ok
entonces vamos a multiplicar aquí por
7-6
y eso nos va a quedar igual a la inversa
de la matriz
x
y eso es igual a x g
entonces x es igual
1 entre 30
a ver primera fila por primera columna 7
por 6 42 más menos 2 por 6 o sea menos
12 42 menos 12 esos son 30 y ahora
segunda fila por primera columna 6 por 7
42 más 3 por 618 estos son 42 más 18
esos son 60
60 y metemos el escalar 1 entre 30
dentro del vector y nos queda 30 entre
30 eso es igual a 11
y 60 entre 30 eso es igual a 12
entonces el vector x es igual el vector
x 12 eso lo que nos dice es que x es
igual a 1 y tiene que ser igual a 2
qué x tiene que ser igual a 1 y que
tiene que ser igual a 2
y eso qué es lo que nos dice pues aquí
teníamos que si multiplicamos el vector
a x veces y le sumamos el vector b ya
veces aquí lo tenemos más claro a por x
más ve por el escalar y nos daba el
vector c aunque pero ya vimos que para
que eso pase entonces los números xy se
tienen que resolver este problema en
donde hay que encontrar el vector x y
para resolver esta ecuación de matrices
pues nada más tenemos que encontrar la
inversa de la matriz a y multiplicarla
por el vector 7-6 y con eso tenemos que
x tiene que ser igual a 1 que tiene que
ser igual a 2 entonces aquí x tiene que
ser igual a 1 y ya tiene que ser igual a
dos y eso lo que nos dice es que si
sumamos una vez el vector a y dos veces
el vector b lo que vamos a obtener es el
vector c que y vamos a verlo aquí
gráficamente si no sale en realidad lo
que vamos a estar viendo es que también
hice yo este dibujo
a ver aquí ya tenemos una vez el vector
a y queremos sumarle dos veces el vector
b y el vector de lo que es 2 hacia la
derecha y 6 hacia arriba entonces saber
estamos aquí y nos trasladamos 2 hacia
la derecha y luego 6 hacia arriba que
hay aquí tenemos justo 1 2 3 4 5 6 o sea
que nuestro siguiente vector va a quedar
por acá en este punto es una vez el
vector a más una vez el vector b y ahora
le volvemos a sumar el vector b otra vez
o sea son otros dos hacia la derecha o
sea por aquí y luego 6 hacia arriba 1 2
3 4 5 6 o sea está como por aquí que es
justo donde estaba el vector c aquí hay
todo este recorrido es una vez el vector
dos veces el vector de y en efecto aquí
mismo este dibujo nos enseña que 1a 2b
si es igual a c porque este vector de
por acá es el vector c ok entonces lo
resolvimos algebraica mente y lo
visualizamos geométricamente en los ejes
cartesianos pero lo que realmente
estamos aprendiendo aquí el verdadero
descubrimiento en este vídeo es que la
representación con matrices puede estar
representando al mismo tiempo muchísimos
problemas distintos este problema se
trataba de encontrar qué combinación
lineal de los vectores a ive debíamos
tomar para obtener el vector c pero en
el vídeo pasado la misma representación
matricial se usaba para encontrar la
intersección de dos líneas y a la hora
de representar a ambos problemas con
matrices obtuvimos la misma
representación matricial y eso lo que
nos dice es que ambos problemas están
relacionados de una forma muy profunda
que si les quitamos el barniz del mundo
real en el fondo son la misma
y es por este tipo de cosas que las
matemáticas son tan interesantes porque
cuando te das cuenta de que dos
problemas son en realidad el mismo se
desvanece esa capa humana de barniz y
superficial porque nuestros cerebros
están construidos para percibir al mundo
de cierta forma pero también nos dice
que hay verdades fundamentales
independientes de nuestra percepción que
unen a todos estos distintos conceptos
en fin la verdad la verdad no me quiero
poner tan mística pero pues si estás
viendo el misticismo que hay a veces
detrás de las matemáticas pues que pare
con un poco de suerte encontraste algo
interesante lo que dije y bueno un
montón de personas toman la clase de
álgebra lineal y aprenden a hacer todo
este tipo de cosas pero al final se
preguntan que cuál es el sentido de todo
esto del álgebra lineal de la vida del
universo y de todo
pero a mí me parece que es algo muy
interesante y otra pregunta también muy
interesante aquí teníamos estos dos
vectores a ive y vimos que si sumamos
una vez el vector a y dos veces al
vector b obtenemos el vector c entonces
la otra pregunta interesante es cuáles
son todos los vectores que podemos
obtener sumando combinaciones de los
vectores a ive se vale multiplicar por
negativos por fracciones por racionales
por cualquier número real que se te
ocurra en realidad lo que estamos
haciendo es preguntando cuáles son todos
los vectores que se pueden escribir como
una combinación lineal de los vectores
ahí ve vamos a hacer más de este tipo de
cosas en álgebra lineal y bueno aquí lo
que tenemos es un espacio euclidiano de
dimensión 2 podríamos también habernos
preguntado lo mismo pero en un espacio
de dimensión 3 o incluso en un espacio
de dimensión n en ese caso se vuelve
todo muy
muy abstracto pero también muy padre
bueno esto creo que terminó siendo una
muy buena embarrada de álgebra lineal y
pues espero que no te haya confundido
demasiado y te veo en el próximo vídeo